how many tickets
accidents incidents have you been in the
last handful of years and how many cops
say oh mr bet david good to see you
again how often does that happen
that's a lot okay that's a lot okay so
imagine if that was zero but i get a
chance to meet a cop and we talk
about this relationship i'm good how are
you feeling so your family
must talk to the police adam it's called
networking
yeah patrick's future in politics yes
okay
if i'm driving how do you spin something
like that i'm good i got to meet a great
i like having a neutral relationship
with cops i don't want to talk to you
you don't need to talk to me
i'm not going to wait on you you need to
have a job neutral relationship with a
woman who can procreate i have a lot of
he caught me racing in a z06 and i was
racing a motorcycle
oops okay and by the way jennifer's in
my car so i'm on the left
he's over here okay the bike and i said
you want to go he said let's go and i'm
in victorville out of all the places so
i'm thinking no cops i'm going to be
safe
so he says ready says let's go we go
takes off
i'm going 135 miles an hour cop pulls me
over
i'm like get that and this is like
reckless driving at the highest level
jennifer's like i told babe i told you i
told you but and so cop comes up
i said he says do you know why i pulled
you over i said yeah because i beat you
you couldn't
he touch cracking up he starts laughing
i said
i said i beat you you couldn't care the
only reason you economy is because of
red light
so what the hell is the matter with you
it says you realize that's reckless
traffic i said listen can you let me go
i don't do this often he says based on
your record you do i said yeah
exactly he says you know what forget
about it your craziest guy i've met go
just let you go you didn't give me
tickets
officer jones wherever you are shout out
to you and victor will you're amazing
tell you
hey jones come out to florida by the way
by the way
c06 z06 going up against the bike guess
what the bike did
destroyed the z06 what's the bike that's
a jigsaw
destroyed the zosin destroyed
the zeus you want to know where i'm at
with this i have zero clue what a z06 is
a jigsaw
nothing yeah my uber would have my uber
would have become in last place
okay do you know can i ask you a
question yes ma'am
women like men who understand cars okay
so start
start studying that's true but he knows
he knows bicycles
oh god that's hot dude
get out my handlebars david who needs
wine when you've got bicycles i hope you
got a big trunk i'm gonna stick my bike
in it but
what did you just say that out loud
that's a 40 year old virgin reference
uh the movie by the way so you and cuomo
wouldn't be too far off if you were his
age that's my guy
you may as well call you adam cuomo you
know
let's not start that let's just stick
with the soybean all right okay here's
the trivia question for you
i'm with pat we're we show up la land
lax boom we get a car
it's waiting there for this guy like the
prince just arrived we show up
bentley sitting there miyu and tiko boom
we're hanging
all right i'm in i'm in he's like adam
welcome to my world right you know i'm
like all right i'm in l.a
i'm on the 405. brand new maybe a couple
hundred miles on this bench
400 000 patch drive
danny majeed thank you danny thank you
danny pat says let's
let's test this bad boy out how fast
this is the 405 is that the 405 this is
the freeway but it's covered 405
okay whatever that means that means that
there's not a lot of changes
okay there was traffic galore okay
go ahead tell your story i don't want to
mess this up what's your point
pat starts driving pushes the bentley
how fast well wait i asked you a
question first he goes what's the
fastest you've ever i said what's the
fastest you've ever been in a car yeah
that's courtesy
yeah i give you the courtesy and then
you said what i'm like maybe 105 maybe i
don't know 110.
i said how about we make history
together then i asked the question he
said sure
so you gave permission for us to make
history together and then what happened
yeah yeah yeah he i there was consent
there i was like cuomo
that's where i'm going how many times
have you said that to a woman
well played sir well played how fast
danielle
do you think mr bet david took the belly
on the 405.
a buck 40. a buck 40. you took the under
uh can i reveal or do you want to just
so you know for all the officers that
are listening to this
this is pure speculation he's assuming
this is where we went but go ahead tell
him what you saw
he hit 150 155 i was close
and that wasn't enough for him danielle
so he said let's do it again the remix
we hit 165.
yeah 165 miles per hour what did it feel
like
it felt like we were driving sideways i
can't it was 165. it felt like we were
going 70.
we were passing cars in the freeway as
if you're going 100 miles an hour and
they're parked
165 miles per hour so now you know
when i say pass maybe you need a driver
pat maybe you need a
you need you need to call our good
friend friend of the show elon musk
and maybe driverless cars and what do i
drive today
i drive a shelby big ass shelby truck
that i go around if i hit curbs and
you feel nothing but your your rear view
mirror your side view mirror somebody
hit it i wasn't in the car
somebody hit it and ran off i chased him
down but when somebody hit your
tire the guy hits my tire yeah do you
remember the picture that car what
happened that they hit my tire on a turn
they accidentally hit my their entire
side was
trashed and i'm looking at it i'm like
what the hell happened to the car
nothing just scratches on the tire the
shelby truck destroyed the car
you know it's crazy do you know what a
shelby is yes because women like uh guys
who know about cars i don't know if you
know about that i heard i heard a thing
or two
we go to we go to um and then you got
the the suv
and then you messed up the tires i
bought the escalade first time i drove
it i
tore the tire i first time first down
yeah ten miles
past the car well first of all here when
you drive it's very if you think about
it when you're driving trucks it's not a
good idea to drive drugs every time i
come up i'm like you know what
i'm every time i'm hitting the side but
can can we avoid talking about my my
uh driving abilities and speed limits
does seem to be a bit
there's a point hit it got it hit it
let's see it daniel what are you
drinking by the way
i drive a big-ass escalade big ass
escalator the right one to drive
b-a-e we go to we go to lunch and this
is in uh miami
and we we leave the it's raining we
dropped the cars off
uh oh no i'm sorry pat says uh we
dropped the kids off i said all right
let me let me let me go deal with the
valet i'm gonna jump out we're draining
or ever go to the restaurant
the valet guy i don't know nothing about
cars it's like dude
shelby what's up i'm like yeah all right
cool buddy take the keys of the truck
we come back out he goes i gotta tell
you this is the valet guy he goes i
drive lamborghinis
i drive ferraris but the shelby
my number one vehicle i was like really
the truck but this shelby i guess is a
big deal
man even when he knows his engine we
even went into
uh prestige auto looking at ridiculous
cars down in miami
and the guy was super impressed with
this paganis and bugatti yeah we were
looking at real cars
yes cars cars cars but the shelby was
like the talking only make 500 of them
they don't make that many of them so
you know seven horsepower they have cars
for dummies it's like a whole book you
can read
yeah and you can procreate right so
creation goes through yes
my question to you danielle is he's
gonna make history is
is is what happened to today's tied to
the ability to
have a car payment is that what's going
on no no no no no you've got to
you've got money you have this is not
mine here's your future line
i buy my car's cash okay you could i
could do that you could
if you were to buy one would you would
you still do a range rover dear or maybe
that e3
e500 you saw like an e-class i did like
a nice
mercedes b-class mercedes that could be
dope go for the grand what
v12 yeah go for it i don't see you as a
lexus guy don't do lexus
that's for you you know you know what's
crazy is i actually bought my ex alexis
that's the only car
the rhymes actually yeah i feel like i'm
not my guy
you think adam's a tesla kind of guy
yeah by the way
by the way i actually see him as yeah
yeah it's got style it's got
you know what else i really see him in
no joke no joke
i see him in a nice 911. oh yeah
i see him in a night i think it's a 911.
oh my gosh
of course focus 9 11. i love it ford
focus
did you really say you don't know what
honestly you don't know what the 99 is
what i just thought
is that a portrait this is not is it a
portrait i almost said you're never
going to get lazy
skip today's podcast okay what's a 911
listen
okay you want to talk about getting late
let me tell you something
he's going to make history he's going to
make history he does everything
i would live in south when i would be
where miami this weekend yes i live in
south beach
i had a sick apartment okay in the
marquee
okay and um
here it is a loft amazing like
my friend called it a abajo
like a penny dropper apartment so you go
out to south beach you meet girls
whatever
you take an uber back to your place they
don't give two shits about what kind of
car you drive they're in your apartment
it's great
that's my point like you never have to
like bro i'm just telling you
times have changed i don't think i don't
think anything's changed disputing
yes your uh uh uh track record
uh with how well of a prospector you are
we've all witnessed it you know how how
well you are
his approach is so great this is adam he
goes to place hey ladies i have some
friends here how are you good
let me introduce you yeah basic script
he's got he just goes
for my friends here yeah except for paul
i have not been the recipient of any of
adam's goodwill well i think
i've taken bullets
oh my god i tried to help paul out he's
like you can't help the
the unhelpable you cannot i'll tell you
the one story i told about paul
when i just moved to dallas we're going
to a bar and
i have no clue where we're going so who
do i want to ask any nice
local lady hey ladies like are we in the
right direction through the good part of
town like
they're like yeah yeah go that way
there's bars thank you thank you cuckoo
cool
after one or two girls that we speak to
paul's like i have the gps right here
why don't you keep asking all these
girls it was literally like five feet of
drugs
i just naturally couldn't
[Laughter]
why do you keep asking these pretty
girls for directions i have the gps
like what are you doing bro i don't like
looking clueless though
you know play dumb girls like
intelligent people too
yeah that's working out well for you
guys yeah it does i do fine
i do just fine shout out to all my
ladies out there
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you